the united states has marked the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 and the deadly
terror attacks that would change the
course of history at ground zero in new
york city relatives read aloud the names
of the almost 3 000 people killed
commemorations also took place at the
pentagon in virginia and shanksville
pennsylvania the sites of the other
crashes
family members of those who perished
paid tribute to the lives cut short by
the attacks
2977 lives a loss at still haunts
america
the new york police and fire department
bands played at hundreds of funerals
perceptions of presidents were shaped
and redefined that day
when the bell tolled for so many
on a bright september morning
much like
today these 20 years have felt like both
a long time
and a short time
and as we recite the names of those we
lost
my memory goes back to that terrible day
when it felt like an evil specter had
descended on our world
but it was also a time when many people
acted above
and beyond the ordinary
gordon m ammoth
[Music]
they were died traders and flight
attendants
cleaners and tourists
young and old rich and poor firefighters
and police officers
a generation has been born since then
marked by the legacy
you pop-up and dad have inspired me to
fall in your footsteps and become a
firefighter too we hope you will
continue to watch us to watch over us
and keep us healthy and safe we love you
so much uncle chris
in washington officials at the pentagon
marked the moment
[Music]
a plane draw a hole in the center of u.s
military power
the attacks posed a grim challenge to
superpower america's might
it responded with a war on terror
many more soldiers would lose their
lives in its name
[Music]
and many of the 13 brave men and women
who just days ago gave their lives
to save others in afghanistan were
babies back in 2001.
september 11th final attack
the hijacking of united flight 93
its passengers rested back control of
the plane from its hijackers it went
down in a pennsylvania field
the man who led america through 9 11
remembered the day's heroes who helped
one another that morning
on america's day of trial and grief
i saw millions of people instinctively
grab for a neighbor's hand
and rally to the cause of one another
that unity born of trauma and grief on
september 11th did not endure
but what has lasted are people's
memories of those who perished that day
the large gathering at ground zero this
anniversary a reminder of that time
when america seemed to stand as one
[Music]
and dw correspondent carolina chamoy is
reporting for us from new york city
carolina you are at ground zero where
the twin towers once stood can you talk
us through the atmosphere there today
claire was a very sad a very emotional
atmosphere at that ceremony people were
telling or sharing the stories of their
family members of their friends who died
on 9 11 and there were also this moment
of silence matching the very same
moments when this tragic events
happened
like for example at 8 24 when the first
plane hit the first tower on the north
face or 903
when the second plane hit exactly the
building that was standing here this was
the second
tower in the world trade center and now
look at all these roses and flags from
people who have been coming here all
these names um there's even a name and
then as you can see there's the letters
and her unborn child so behind every one
of these names and these roses there's a
very personal a very emotional story and
that was the atmosphere also today and
these people and their stories that was
in the focus of the ceremony
now at the commemoration today in new
york city what stood out to you the most
the personal stories um mothers telling
you about their sons who for example
were paramedics and went into the
building and rescued people at least
three people that was a woman from
puerto rico telling me this story and
then he went a fourth time in there yeah
of course thinking and knowing he was a
hero but he never came out and so when
people are telling you these stories
you just you don't have anything to say
it was really sad and i think um
it was very important to have these
stories in the focus of the ceremony and
as they all say to never forget what
happened in 2001
now on this anniversary of 9 11. has
there also been reflection about how the
event marked the beginning of a new era
in the united states and indeed in the
world
yeah i would say a lot of things changed
clear after 9 11 domestic politics and
the patriot act changed for example the
surveillance laws um people policemen
were allowed to go into
private households to to to report on
things to check on things without an
official permit um also well for example
one of the things we have all noticed
are the whole checking procedures at the
airports this wasn't like that before 9
11. this changed after 9 11. and
regarding um foreign affairs and the war
on terror this was probably the most
important point germany also
participated and supported the united
states in this war and that was also the
day after 9 11 when the war in
afghanistan started so a lot of things
changed not only for the united states
not only for new york but for the whole
world
indeed 20 years on they continue to
affect the world we live in carolina
tremoy there for us in new york city
thank you so much for that update
you